a dried chili pepper in the patty
whoa there it is wow just comes out of
nowhere
[Music]
whoa
at its core a burger is pure meat cheese
bun
but if i've learned anything hosting
this show it's that a burger is always
evolving
and when immigrant and first generation
chefs reimagine the burger
it's a whole different story today i'm
reuniting with my friend
youtuber casey neistat i'm going to take
him on an epic
international burger tour to taste test
three mind-blowing
burgers that you don't want to miss
[Music]
casey good to see you again good to see
you six feet apart of course
i know i like just want to give you a
hug i know it's not loud it's wild
i mean yo we pulled out all the stops
look at you know
you got this beautiful diner yeah we're
like to be honest i expect a little bit
more with the food but i understand that
this is plastic it is plastic these are
props that just happen to be
in this amazing diner that we're
shooting this in right now
you're a year into living in los angeles
what are the difference between
new york burgers la burgers i would say
that like the la burger scene i think is
top notch
i'm having a better time finding burgers
out here
that are exciting and new and fresh were
amazing um
that i think i did in new york but like
the the pizza thing makes me a little
bit sad
l.a pizza sucks sucks and anybody who
says it's not
yeah we're not even close no it's like
not even on the same level
the last time we were in new york we
went to the
the shake shack innovation lab we had
some amazing
secret off menu hard to get lines out
the door style burgers
and then now we're in la we're in a 50s
diner
where you would think that we would eat
a burger that kind of looks something
like this
right but we're not we're in los angeles
we're
in a melting pot or a mosaic of
different cultures and
and and today what i wanted to do with
you was
to try burgers from all walks of life
here in los angeles
great let's go i'm starving
my name is daniel sun i'm the chef owner
of katju sando here in chinatown
we're really inspired by yoshoku cuisine
which is
a western style foods desperate
influence to japanese
cuisine or culture as well as
convenience store foods so it is sort of
our
love letter from japan the word menchie
literally translates into
minced or minced meat beef cutlet
it basically is the burger katsu of
japan
the best way i would describe it is like
the crispiest burger with the crust
sealing the juices of the meat
when we literally cut the sandwich in
half like as we're pulling
juice will run mostly all cut sandal
restaurants or katsu sandos have
used some sort of milk bread which is
also known as shokupan
our sandos are with our our own original
recipe honey milk bread
the type of beef that we use for our
menchie is australian wagyu we
caramelize onions for about four hours
in
a5 wagyu fat and we render that out to a
point where it's basically a jam
and so it's sort of like an umami bomb
that acts as its own seasoning asian
i would say one tenderloin is about
almost a thousand dollars we're probably
not making any money on it
but then you know we gotta we gotta make
it we gotta just make it memorable right
so
we pride ourselves in using something
called namapanco in our breading
procedure and we actually import our
namapango from japan
we create our own slaw that's sort of an
homage to like a normal
katsu restaurant that serves cabbage
slaw on the side with a little bit of
miso dressing
it really is just a refreshing hello i
would say like being a korean american
in la cooking in yoshiku cuisine and
introducing katsu sandoz is like
i feel just right it feels like i'm
right in place there are no rules
it's arms wide open food and i think
like
dementia is something that should
absolutely be proud to be
in the conversation this is
the katsu-sando menchi burger they just
opened in chinatown
right across the street from where i'm
at i'm not gonna lie to you i've had
this before i've had it a lot
it's crack it's basically
like a burger that you would get in a
japanese convenience store if you go to
katsu sando
it looks like a japanese convenience
store they have like all the drinks and
the candies
and this beautiful beast right here he
takes the
meat patties it and then breads it and
then frying it
and then fries it look at that ooh baby
oh my god lots of umami going on in
there my tongue is on
high alert it's like fireworks going on
right now you know it's funny if i like
close my eyes and bite into this i don't
know that i would come back and say it's
a
it tastes like a burger right and by
definition
a burger is ground meat in between a bun
bun chopped meat qualifies
no it's fantastic i'm such a loyalist
when it comes to burgers this is way
outside the wheelhouse but my god
there's bread holy [ __ ] it's so good so
this kind of reminds me
of louie's lunch in connecticut right
because i served between bread
exactly i'm i'm getting like the brick
wall
smithsonian style lives right now too at
the same time so it's not that far off
right so it went around the world but it
came full circle you can tell it's still
uniquely
japanese in its own in its own right
it's a great
representation of the american burger
on to the next burger let's go
[Music]
this is knuckle owner of with mush this
is arjun
owner of madmash but mash is bad ass
it's the first [ __ ] indian restaurant
to do it
you already know what time it is i'm an
addict for sneakers buttered chicken and
[ __ ] were bipass
here at budmosh we serve the spiced lamb
burger
it's one of the cornerstones of our menu
because we are
american indian indian in america and
the most
american thing you can eat is a
hamburger our parents used to have lots
of friends over in the summers
weather's nice so it's everyone's in the
backyard barbecuing
there was this huge spread of indian
food and then for
us kids we were just like we don't want
indian food
i always eat indian food i want hot dogs
i want hamburgers like i distinctly
remember
our uncle dad's older brother the man
him laughing at me saying okay just
throw the lamb kebab in the burger it's
lamb burger
yeah straight up first things first we
start with good meat and good bread
so our meat is a new zealand lamb shank
we clean and butcher them in-house grind
them in-house every single morning we
add
some spice and some flavors to it finely
chopped onions
serrano pepper and other indian spices
our first thought was like
it's got to have a crunch and it's got
to have some onion bite because that's
an indian thing
we created this paprika spice mayo and
it's kind of like our version of like an
indian secret sauce me and uncle were
hanging out
hanging out we got a call got a call
alvin kailan hit me up on the one two
one two pick up the phone hello and he
said yo
burger show pulling up pull up do
something dumb dumb
cheeseburger samosa hosa it happened so
i was like all right
bun samosa triangle of of meat
a triangle of american cheese a triangle
of meat triangle of american cheese
fold over the short toe pastry
press and seal and then
drop it in the fryer dunk it
shout out to marco marco markham canada
cowan and dennison you already know what
time is it middle field what up
hard meat what up what up
this is burger number two the spiced
lamb burger
from bodmash and you're in for a treat
and what
what's this like this is a samosa what
is this yeah
so as a surprise okay because they're my
brothers
i've been trying to get them to make
this for a really long time
finally want to debut the
cheeseburger samosa it's a special treat
it's not
available at the restaurant yet but
this is gonna be fantastic
[Music]
wow that is special that is just as good
holy smokes that's the first time i had
it this is one of those things where
if i take my wife here and i introduce
you to this burger
i'm gonna be on good terms there for
like a month you have to take her that's
how good this burger is the spiced lamb
the raw onion the tomato the sweetness
of the bun
does something with the spiciness of the
lamb and it's like
it's a really good marriage it's
basically lamb kebab
but pattied out like a burger in
burger form and honestly it's one of los
angeles
gems yeah no kidding fantastic
i can't wait to try the next one okay
what's the order of operation here for
this so
from what i'm told okay you dip it into
this special
burger sauce okay and then kind of scoop
up some lettuce
and then you take a bite
oh wow this dough has a doughnut vibe
going mm-hmm
it was so good the cheese is like
perfectly melted it's super hot
when i have good burgers and there's
like shredded lettuce left
on like a plate i always scoop it up
like that it's the best salad you've
ever had yeah
is this going to be on the menu if not
i'm going to tell them to make it for me
and i'll put it on my mind
again it shows the diversity of like
what a burger can be
putting your love your culture your
family into it
you feel it the taste that this has is a
completely different world
so the third burger okay i'm a little
worried
uh-oh it's gonna kick our butt it's
legendary here in los angeles okay was
that deliberately left last
because these were burgers that just
give you a kiss right on the face and
say i love you and now we're going to
get our ass
now we're going to now we're going to
get we're going to get tested
i'm ready i brought my a-game you know
you're a veteran yeah i did that last
dab
what are the questions here all right
let's do let's do the next one let's go
uh my name is jaz singh sanong i'm a
co-owner of
i born in southern thailand i came to
america in 1979 with one suitcase and
200
i think southern thai people eat very
very strong pests
and very very spicy it's crazy spicy
crazy then howlingly chicken have to be
very tasty
not like chili burn and no taste at all
here
spicy but tasty every time that they
order burger
and i heard the word oh my gosh
burger is spicy because i add the thai
chili inside of the burger that i never
tell anyone
you prepare the lettuce on the plate and
trees fly up tomato and then put the
burger
on slide the red onion on top and slide
the thai chili on top
and then pour them with the yellow sauce
and red salt juicy
flavorful and spicy no ketchup yeah i
met i made my
my burger to comfort my kid to go to
school
she feel like she not look like them you
know like they eat burger they eat
american food and she don't have
american food from home
when did she what kid the burger not
spicy when i sent to her school
but when you walk into chitladar all my
food is spicy i cannot serve you
regular burger jit that means hard and
lada
another word that means woman woman
heart
women have a good heart here it is it
doesn't look like a burger nope it kind
of looks like a salad
yep i'm a little worried because like
your crew here like came over urgently
with this stack
of napkins and then they've also been
like secretly
surrounding me with water bottles yeah
just kind of giving me this look of
of compassion and sympathy like
good luck soldier you're gonna need it
this has made all the top lists burger
lists in los angeles for
years okay so it's got to be good i'm
ready and what's the approach here what
what do you advise like is there
anything
i need to make sure i'm getting you know
something i want to avoid this for
let's get a bite let's put everything
okay well i'm going right into the heart
then
do you think this bite is too ambitious
we're going to find out okay
salud my mouth just said that they were
like completely coated
it's protecting itself
all right here we go
[Music]
whoa there it is wow it just comes out
of nowhere like a
whoa there's like a car accident in my
mouth
sweet it's like that candy that baruch
assault had where she's like
now i taste turkey dinner and she's like
blueberry pie
because when it first hits your mouth
you're like yo this [ __ ] is sweet and
delicious yeah and all of a sudden it's
like
it's like oh cool there's a little spice
here and then it's like
and then it's like hey man you just
crashed your car into a building
it was a mistake to start talking mid
bike
because it creeps on you i'm really
surprising myself over here this is
it gets hotter this is fantastic yeah
where's the heat coming from look at
what i just cut this
okay what'd you find uh-huh
busted this is in the patty there's a
chili pepper
a dried chili pepper in the patty that
is what's killing me
and i completely understand how
necessary like these
huge hunks of iceberg lettuce are like
the coolness of the lettuce the coolness
of the tomato
this is a 10 out of 10 home run for me
over here i love it it's
this is extraordinary it's in and around
the confines of a burger
a brilliant chef that i know told me
that
some think of spice as like
an excuse to cover up for a lack of
flavor right
and this guy was a genius
he told me that like 10 minutes ago you
guys did not oversell the spiciness it's
as hot
as you said it would be but it is such
an enjoyable heat
and like that such a purposeful heat if
you had to pick one
which one are you going back to yeah i
feel like i was going on and on about
the lamb burger and bringing my wife
there but
this stands alone like this is i say
this without trying to like
be hyperbolic or anything like this is
one of the best culinary experiences
i've ever had in my entire life
this is a game changer anything like
this as much as
they are so different from the meat
cheese bun experience that we
sell on this show these are still
hamburgers
and if this is the future of burgers i'm
psyched
i'm excited dude casey thanks for
sharing
this international tour of burgers with
me thanks for having me thanks for the
burgers and are you guys gonna have one
of these
no it's that [ __ ] good i'm not
kidding this is like
this is really extraordinary
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you